Marvel Studios and the Russo brothers
have given us several sneak peeks at
Avengers and game but comments from the
directors and tricks they've played on
the audience before have us wondering
whether what we've really seen tells us
the truth about what to expect from the
movie Trust is built over time and Joe
and Anthony Russo have proven that the
only thing we can really count on from
them is a well-made movie everything
else is questionable look no further
than the trailer for Avengers infinity
war one shot shows the entire team
including the Hulk running at the screen
in Wakanda but when the film arrived the
shot was nowhere to be found in an
interview with slash film Joe and
Anthony Russo admitted to changing
trailers to misdirect viewers saying at
our disposal are lots of different shots
that aren't in the movie that we can
manipulate through CG to tell a story
that we want to tell specifically for
the purpose of the trailer and not for
the film as many observers pointed out
Joe Russo also appeared to straight-up
lie about the title of Avengers endgame
when asked if it was ever spoken in
infinity war the director said no but
we're in the endgame when the first
trailer for endgame dropped reports
swirled that the movie's promotional
clips would only feature footage from
the first 15 or 20 minutes with a final
cut that clocks in at over three hours
that leaves a lot of the movie on scene
according to Marvel boss Kevin Feige
those reports are quote somewhat
accurate but the vagueness of his
comment leaves open the possibility that
Marvel could throw in a quick shot or
two from a later sequence it's hard to
believe that everything is coming from
the beginning of the movie there have
been plenty of clips of the team sulking
around in the aftermath of Thanos is
decimation but there have also been
several action sequences and a variety
of costume changes
Black Widow having both short blonde and
long red hair seems to indicate that a
lot of ground is being covered since
Iron Man and Captain America threw down
in Captain America's Civil War fans have
been anxiously awaiting the inevitable
reunion of Tony Stark and Steve Rogers
it seemed a safe bet that we'd get some
kind of movement between the two an
infinity war but it didn't happen the
end game special looks spot did reveal
an emotional scene
when the two heroes as they
reestablished their trust you trust me
and two fans everywhere rejoiced until
the Russos dropped a bomb in an
interview not long after Joe Russo
announced that the shot wasn't in the
movie
Anthony teased the different possibility
maybe it's in the movie the brothers
laughed with glee as they tortured
bewildered Marvel fans with the
possibility that we may not see Rodgers
and stark reconcile it's hard to believe
they deny the audience a chance to see
some closure for one of the cornerstone
relationships in the MCU but if it
happens it might look a lot different
than that one particular shocked
Hulk being inserted into infinity war
footage where he didn't belong let fans
know that all bets were off heading into
endgame promotion as the advance looks
have trickled out of Marvel's tightly
sealed vault the speculation has swung
from who's being added in to who's being
cropped out the Super Bowl spot in
particular got a ton of attention due to
a couple of shots that seemed to
deliberately leave gaps between
characters fans pointed out that a shot
showing cap and the team looking up into
the sky had a huge empty area while the
first shot of the crew's striding in
slo-mo threw the Avengers HQ hanger
seemed to also have an unevenly spaced
gap while speculation on this level
would normally be left for the most
obsessive fans the fact that we've seen
two completely different shots of Thor's
axe in the endgame trailers has made it
a topic of wider interest fans love
seeing the Green Machine do his thing
and yet we haven't seen him in action
since he's squared off against Thanos
and was soundly beaten during the
opening moments of infinity war the fact
that he's about to finish a three movie
story arc has fans on the edge of their
seats to see how his story will play out
many are expecting to finally see
Professor Hulk in action while others
think endgame may be the Jay giant swan
song whatever the case the fact that the
marketers refused to put a clip of Hulk
into the end game promotional footage is
maddening Bruce Banner has shown up
multiple times but the fact that the
Russos haven't allowed the slightest
glimpse of Green on the screen makes one
wonder what exactly they're hiding the
special look trailer finally had a shot
of Thanos geared up and ready for action
again he's covered head-to-toe
armored while apparently beaming down to
a location so why is he wearing armor as
infinity war plays out Thanos slowly
leaves his armor behind eventually
unneeded now that he has the Infinity
stones to protect him
perhaps the Infinity Gauntlet simply
broke during the snap which is a
scenario that Joe Russo has implied as
being plausible another possibility is
that the scene occurs while the Avengers
are traveling through time time travel
in the quantum realm are heavily
rumoured to play a big part in the movie
so there's a possibility that our heroes
could be fighting vanos in the past and
don't get sucked into a time vortex we
won't be able to save you it's fun to
get worked up over feeling betrayed by
the Russos but the truth is they're
doing it mostly out of love speaking
with Empire Joe Russo summed up the
directors feelings perfectly when he
said the thing that's most important to
us is that we preserve the surprise of
the narrative this talented pair of
directors isn't just trolling fans for
the fun of it they're aware that they're
sitting on a goldmine of information
that tens of millions of fans can't wait
to see they want the experience to be a
good one not spoiled by bad timing or
too much information Joe Russo added
when I was a kid and saw the Empire
Strikes Back at 11:00 a.m. on the day it
opened it so profoundly moved me because
I didn't know a damn thing about the
story I was going to watch we're trying
to replicate that experience check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about Avengers
endgame are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]